qu'est ce que je peux me foucard tout
seul allez-vous zotto poucave et oui à
écouter autopont qu'avez vous qu'est-ce
qui se passe alors j'ai rêvé de vous le
nid dernier
[Applaudissements]
on voudrait les explications mais bien
sûr je sais pas vous était vendeur de
souche et fo avaient fait pas des radars
au dessus no12 faire du salon répond je
suis au psg avait pas la personne
respectée là quand même
merci oui on roule justement je laissais
mois raconté la suite bien sûr bonsoir
on était tous ensemble
là vraiment ça on passe vraiment du rêve
au cauchemar
vraiment pas ça m'a même réveillée dans
la nuit
c'est qu'en fait on vous l émission voix
sur une patinoire dans est en fait cyril
et moi nous étions deux grands patineurs
artistiques mais vraiment les votants du
monde et on patinait ensemble et c'était
magnifique et puis tout on était autour
de nous comme ça on vous pouvez me dire
comment s'appelle boulot copains avec
qui vous êtes parti au portugal
axel axel donc ce n'est pas moi que vous
avez rêvé à double axel double axel
et oui en fait de l'arrivée à la
transférer le double axel vim
et allah elle s'est vu perdre la
patinage du patinage à madame oui mais
là c'est vous ces fines lamelles vallée
bon maire sur les chaînes wilkinson là
nous emmerder merci et nous a pas pu
rouler un patin alors c'est quoi
non on voulait que man on atteint ce
talent une patinoire sérieusement on
installe une patinoire un peu plus on
fait des couples de banias et ont fait
des ont fait des chorégraphies à la
patinoire directement quand ma demande
d'admission sur la bad ce oui mais
attendez vous savez comme moi j'ai des
impératifs budget quelqu'un dont la
spécialité de décoder les rêves
il pourrait nous dire exactement la
signification des voitures vous avez 40
minutes on peut trouver quelqu'un finira
comme ça on va pas vite et axel sera
pour demain on invitera quelqu'un à
l'arrêt des codes les oeuvres a non
seulement la palène noah seelam est
grave et on fera les rêves
j'ai trop de trucs à raconter en plaisir
sur les rêves ah ouais mec je croyais
être arrêtée sur ce rêve on verra ce qui
se passe